my lords ladies and gentlemen
it is my most sorrowful duty
to announce to you the death of my
beloved mother the queen
i know how deeply you
the entire nation
and i think i may say the whole world
sympathize with me
in the irreparable loss we've all
suffered
it is the greatest consolation
to me to know of the sympathy expressed
by so many
to my sister and brothers
and that such overwhelming affection
and support
should be extended to our whole family
in our loss
to all of us as a family
as to this kingdom
and
the wider family of nations
of which it is a part
my mother gave an example
of lifelong love
and of selfless service
my mother's reign was unequaled
in its duration
its dedication and its devotion
even as we grieve
we give thanks
for this most faithful life
i am deeply aware
of this great inheritance
and of the duties and heavy
responsibilities
of sovereignty
which have now passed to me
in taking up these responsibilities
i shall strive to follow
the inspiring example
i have been set
in upholding constitutional government
and to seek the peace
harmony and prosperity
of the peoples of these islands
and of the commonwealth's realms and
territories throughout the world
in this purpose i know
that i shall be upheld
by the affection
and loyalty of the peoples whose
sovereign i have been called upon to be
and that in the discharge of these
duties
i will be guided by the council of their
elected parliaments
in all this
i am profoundly encouraged by the
constant support
of my beloved wife
i take this opportunity
to confirm my willingness
and intention
to continue the tradition
of surrendering the hereditary revenues
including the crown estate
to my government for the benefit of all
in return for the sovereign grant
which supports my official duties as
head of state and head of nation
and in carrying out
the heavy task that has been laid upon
me
and to which i now dedicate what remains
to me
of my life
i pray for the guidance and help
of almighty god
i have with humble duty to crave your
majesty's permission for the publication
of your gracious speech
approved
concerning the security of the church of
scotland
i understand that the law requires that
i should
at my accession to the crown
take and subscribe the oath
relating to the security of the church
of scotland
i am ready to do so at this first
opportunity
i
charles iii by the grace of god of the
united kingdom of great britain and
northern ireland
and of my other realms and territories
king
defender of the faith
do faithfully promise and swear that i
shall inviolably maintain
and preserve the settlement of the true
protestant religion
as established by the laws made in
scotland
in prosecution
of the claim of right
and particularly by an act
in tituld
an act for securing the protestant
religion
and presbyterian church government
and by the acts passed in the parliament
of both kingdoms
for union of the two kingdoms
together with the government
worship
discipline rights and privileges
of the church of scotland
so help me god